الظهر وصل حتى الى مناطق بعيده عن تلك
التي ضربها زلزال كهرمان مرش بدات وزاره
البيئه والاسكان وبعض البلديات بمعاينه
مبان قد لا تصمد امام زلازل محتمله
فلا احد يريد تكرار مشاهد تهدم اكثر من 30
الف مبنى
زاد القلق من المباني القديمه خصوصا
المشيده قبل عام 2000 سنسرع عمليات
المعاينه للمباني المحدده كما استقبلنا
طلبات لمعاينه 76 الف بناء في اسطنبول
وحدها حتى الان لكن كيف تتم هذه العمليه
يقول المختصون ان العوامل تتضافر وتبدا من
فحص طبيعه الارض التي شيد عليها البناء
الى هندسته الى المواد المستخدمه
[موسيقى]
تؤخذ العينات الى مختبرات خاصه لفحص
مقاومتها للهزات
نحلل من خلال الات خاصه جوده مواد البناء
والسمك المعادن المستخدمه والخرسانات نحلل
النتائج ونقرر الهدم او الترميم او نؤكد
السلامه وصلابه البناء لكن ما حدث في 11
ولايه منكوبه فرض ضروره تجديد الرقابه
لاسيما بعد الانتقادات التي استهدفت منحه
تراخيص البناء لمتعهدين لم يلتزموا
بمعايير السلامه ايضا
تتحدث السلطات عن عمليه تحول عمراني تشمل
المباني التي ستشيد في انقره اسطنبول
وازمير اولا تتوافق ومعايير السلامه فضربه
زلزال الجنوب التركي كانت ثقيله فرح
الزمان شوقي الجزيره
انقره